تنظمي الينا عبر الهاتف من دمشق الفنانه
القديره منى واصف اهلا بك السيده منى شكرا
على تواجدك معنا في مسائل عربيه ورمضان
كريم نتشرف بوجودك معانا
الله يخليك يا رب وشكرا على هالمقدمه
الجميله جدا
تستاهليها قليله عليك طيب مع نهايه عرض
مسلسل واخيرا سيده منى انتشر فيديو جميل
لكن مع الفنان وسام فارس على الدراجه
ناريه الفيديو نال الكثير من اعجاب
الجمهور شو قصه هالفيديو
والله يعني في مشهد انا اني لما بدي اروح
بعد ما شفت ابني بالتلفزيون بقلب البنك عم
بيهدد العالم وبده مصاري فانا بدي روح
يعني انا بعرف هذه الشريحه اللي عم اقدمها
هي الشريحه الاجتماعيه شركه موتور بتعمل
كل شيء كذا يعني
شايفه انا كتير يعني انا بدرس الشخصيه
والبيئه اللي هيتمنى
ظبطت الامور فكروني اني انا بخاف كلهم
بخافوا علي وانا ما خفت اسم الله عليك يا
سيده منى واحنا بالفعل خلينا بكل لحظه
نعبر عن سعادتنا بوجودك اليوم معنا منوره
مساء العربيه اليوم ست منى خلينا كمان
تسلمي ونتوقف كمان معك اليوم يعني نحاول
نكسب وقت نسالك عند ام ياقوت اخر واحدث
ادوارك كيف شفتي التجربه هالاخيره وخصوصا
انك لبستي فيها الكثير من الواقع المعاش
في لبنان اليوم
يعني كيف بدي اقول لك انا لما باخذ لما
يعني بيوصلي هيك عمل
لازم يعني ادرسوا كثير لحتى ابعدوا عن اخر
عمل انا عملته يلي هو الهيبه
ست سنوات ست سنوات صار انا في عندي غير
اللي بيعرفني في الجمهور ثاني هو جمهور
الاغتراب الجمهور الجيل الثالث هذا كمان
انا ما بدي اياه يقارنني ابدا باي دور
شافه فكانت دراسه كثير مهمه بالنسبه لهذه
الشخصيه وخصوصا اني انا من قبل يعني
بالنسبه البيئات الشعبيه يعني العبايه بس
في ماشي يمكن ما بيعرفه فهذا كنت مهم جدا
ايه كنت مصر جدا اني انا اعمله بطريقه
يعني كيف بدي اقول لك ما هو القفا ياللي
فيه
كمان انا تعبني نفسيا يعني قصه صحيح
بعتمد كثير على هذا المخزون يلي بيجي مع
تراكم مسلمين من خلال الماسي اللي انا
عاشتها بحياتي كانساني وبحياتي كفنانه
وبحياتي اللي بيسمعوني من الناس كله
جواتي بلحظه بيطلع هذا اول شيء طيب ستمونا
اليوم يعني هالسنه في رمضان شاركتي ومثلتي
فيه مسلسل واخيرا بعيدا عن واخيرا اليوم
مع الموسم الرمضاني وزحمه الاعمال
الدراميه في رمضان ما الذي تفضل منى
متابعته وايمن الاعمال لفت نظرك هذا العام
الحقيقه انا اول الكل سعيده جدا بالنسبه
للاعمال السوريه لاني بتعرفي انت خلال
العشر سنوات نحن كنا بشكل الاشكال فيه نوع
من المقاطعه الى حد ما
فهما اثر على الانتاج
ما شاء الله وكان يعني اعمالنا يعني انا
ما في بفتح على محطه عالميه عمل او عملين
او ثلاثه انت كثير مهم بالنسبه الي وفي
انتاج كمان لبناني مشترك مهم انا انا بكبر
قلبي بهذا الشيء اللي عم اشوفه فانا
الحقيقه ما بقدر شو يعني اكثر من اربع
ساعات قلت ما بقدر يعني اربع ساعات اذا
كان كنت عم اشوفه اخيرا مين في قبله
بالنسبه انا بشوفه يعني هذا طبعا يعني ما
بدي اطمن على ابني الاولاني انا بدي اطمن
انا بشوف البنت
انا مشتركه معه يلي هو قصي في عندي ابن
انا ودعته بالفيلم اخر شيء وبقيت لما
ودعته بدي اطمن على هذا العمل مو بس تطمنت
كمان ما شاء الله
هذه الاعمال التي تخصك اليوم وهذا سر ايضا
شهرتك وقيمتك وتقدير الناس لك ست منى
السيده منى اليوم لطالما كان لديك موقفا
واضحا فيما يتعلق بعمليات التجميل
للممثلات وفنانات العصر اليوم هل تعتقدين
بانه صار في مبالغه واصبح من الصعب الحصول
على ممثلات لديهن مواصفات طليق بادوار
تاريخيه مثلا يعني ادوار كانت قبل عمليات
التجميل
ما بعرف انا كيف بدي احكي على عمليات
التجميل انا مو ضده يعني
لانه بتحمل سعاده انا شفت سيدات مو ضروري
فنانات سيدات واتعاملوا عمليات تجميل
صاروا احلى يعني حتى
اتحسنت يعني انا ماني ضد
بس لما بيصيروا كلياتهم بيشبهوا بعض
مثلا تصوري مثلا مثلا انا مثلا يعني شو
بدي اقول لك وحده رايحه مثلا تتدين من عند
السمان
خلينا شعبيه
وكيلو
وكيلو شغله ثانيه بشيل 300 400 خلينا نقول
هلا يعني صار له اكثر وهي عامله عمليه
تجميل 100,000 دولار او 50,000 دولار كيف
بدك تقنعينها بطريقه معينه
من الطرق بس يعني عبد الناس ما فيها مشكله
انا ما عملت
لاني انا اول ما بديت ما اخذوني لموهبتي
انا وجيني يلي طلع بالستينات بسوريا نحن
جيل بنات يعني كنا كنا حلوات بس قصه
الموهبه طلعت بعدين من خلال التمرين من
خلال التجارب سقط فينا من نجاح من تركني
للجمال يعني يجب انه نستوقفك انت كنت
ومازلتي
الحمد لله رب العالمين اهم شيء الصحي هلا
طيب
لك قلتي فيه انه الادوار التي تقدم لي
تناسب سنوات الثمانين وسالحق بكبيره الهند
انديرا جاندي طب ستمونا الكل يحبك ما الذي
ينتظره منى وما اهدافها
ما بعرف
ما بعرف لانه انا
بحياته ما حدا كتبني عرفتي انا بيجيني
دوري
الثقافه 40 سنه بعدين تقعد
انما الرساله هذا هديه من رب العالمين
ما عندي مشكله يعني انا لكن اللي جواتي
انا بحب لو اعمل دور عندي رغد اصلا هي لما
يطلقوا عليها الام ام طبعا يعني شوفي قديش
وهي وهي سياسيا من
ظهر
المكيفه طريقه اهلك لحتى وصلت لما تحكم
الهندي يعني وبعدين هي بتشبه المسرحيات
اللي انا بقدمها نهاياتي كثير مثلا السلطه
القطع الكرسي والسلطه مثلا
انت شلون نهايتك يعني
عمل هذا اذا عملوا لي اياه يعني تكون قفلت
قول شو يعني بيقولوا يعني عملت عمل بمهمه
اواخر عمري يعني
وان شاء الله بنتمنى لك المزيد والمزيد من
التالق وشكرا جزيلا لك شكرا لوقتك الفنان
القديره منى واصف كنت معنا من دمشق شكرا
لك شكرا لك